good morning everyone hello everyone
welcome to this beautiful Wednesday come
by 18 oh yeah are you gonna get your
hump on today of course you're gonna
hump your leg I get my hump on every day
but I'm damn like especially charged up
you know especially Theo we have a sign
we have a sign people have been telling
us like I said been looking for a sign
here it is people been telling us you
need a sign we're like yeah [ __ ] we're
on it and yelled signs take a long time
to make
shout out it was made by a toaster named
Ashley she has a company called Howdy
Doody they made this for us it they came
and installed it yesterday it's so cute
it's soaked and unfortunately there's
like a small crack in the acrylic that
you can't see but they made us anyone
and are shipping it but we're gonna have
this extra one once the new one cut are
we gonna do with shoddy really good
offending your apartment sure know if
you're not even not interested why'd you
have to shoot it I didn't say I wasn't
interested just jati sure
shouting rules of shots so what are you
gonna do with it
I don't know dick or I'm moving so
you're gonna be in your apartment yeah
maybe maybe it's like I don't know I
just want I want the opportunity to do
something with it
okay you'll have the opportunity for
sure anyways it is a beautiful Wednesday
it's cloudy his last show of the week so
we gotta make it count you guys we can't
tell you how good this shows gonna be
cuz we don't know yet but I have a good
feeling about it but tomorrow
Stephen I was about to say Stephen McGee
it's co-hosting with you is better say
Stephen from Laguna Beach was even
Colletti Stephen Colletti is hosting
another dream Stephen McGee is roasting
we're finally gonna get pitch down never
have because he was mysteriously like
replaced from summer house even though
he was honestly the only character worth
worth a dime so good luck but he'll be
not only hosting with Jackie doing the
past five but then a little interview
like kind of what happened where's Lucas
now yeah where's the working circus let
me see them in action what is Steven up
to etc will always be taking your
questions so we'll get the foal around
it's well-rounded story of what's going
down because also summer house is
filming now we're like we gotta start
happening things are moving someone had
a good idea in the comment said we
should raffle this off as a prize like
someone could win it okay can I enter
shadi shadi you can't you guys lose
Jackie and I
recorded an episode last night for our
patreon which is if you want to spend
any tolerance month and get extra
episodes we do five podcast episodes a
month and we did one yesterday we
planned like to meet at five six o'clock
at your apartment yeah so at like 6
o'clock we were facetiming we were you
know doing some work stuff
then I was like alright I'm gonna come
over and you were like I could send well
also monsoon yesterday so like I was
gonna hear you two coming over I
canceled plans that I had had so I was
like you don't have to come over you
don't if you don't eat you I don't think
you realized how ahead we are scheduled
this month so I was like I can come to
you tomorrow like also because she was
like I'm gonna take the yo for a walk
and then I'm gonna bring him over I was
like do not do that like not only is
enough you see just like not really
allowed in our new house but it's
raining out he's gonna be filthy dirty
so so discriminatory I can't even begin
cláudio course do not respect my rules
and came over bring Co to my apartment I
literally had to pick him up outside the
door right we went straight into the
bathroom the drama or the patreon
episode on the floor of my Florentine me
and my son took a tiny bathroom we were
sweating so much honestly one of our
funniest episodes because the treachery
was just like putting me into overdrive
you know for sure like I was remembering
things that I said during the episode
and I was like I don't think I would
have said that if I wasn't under it's
like you know when you're being tortured
and you're forced to give up secrets
that's how I felt like I was being
tortured and I just didn't really care
what I was saying cuz who cares when
you're sweating under your boobs what's
wrong I mean I'm sorry brought me water
earlier and like I forgot it like you
gave me a cup and now I have driving
it's right here oh thank you oh my gosh
in this I'm so thirsty
I'm into thirsty these days RC girl I
mean honestly I'm a fifty thirsty [ __ ]
you really are anyways the patreon
mistimed is available now also if you're
like if 5 episodes sorry sorry if five
episodes in a week is like enough for
you and you don't feel the need for
premium content but you're like wait how
can I support this show that I get for
free every single day and I just want to
give back to these girls right you can
subscribe to our patron subscribe to our
patreon and you also will get early
access to tickets for camp tous which is
like very real now and is almost
available for purchase and early access
to merch
so I'm just a access to all my shows so
you can see for yourself like a real
toaster it's a great community we do
things too
one is I just have a quick housekeeping
out because I'm going to jet up st.
Louis tomorrow st. Louis show is sold
out very sorry not doing a second one
Saturday I'm going to Denver and there's
like 50 tickets left
and I might and clothes on is gonna be
an audience so if you care about CST you
should just be there and then next week
I'm going to Phoenix and I'm very close
to locking down an amazing guest for the
show don't say I don't want to jinx it
but not gonna act right now we have I
already know but you guys it's premium
as hell I might have to get on a flight
if ya know if it happens you have to
come okay also did you watch other
Island no but I asked Zach I was like
hey give me my shirt alien who's like II
would hate it I'm not watching that
tonight he was like but we can watch a
movie and we watched blockers finally Oh
was great and so I'm ready to talk about
it it was great it was very strange or a
few things that wait a bit yeah a little
stupid like when we first started
watching and I was having like a
bachelorette moment when I just couldn't
focus on the movie at hand but then it
went on and I hate movies where it's
like everything goes wrong and we're on
like a manhunt like that movie are we
there yet
like I agree I hate movies I think it's
like a journey right but there were a
few moments that we were laughing out
loud there me too and I wanted to lose
the super settle and John Cena is butt
chuggin mark that was funny - that was
good
please come and he spits it out yeah I
thought that was kind of gross laughing
so hard when Leslie Mann is behind the
TV in bed were died she literally
collapsed it was the best acting I've
ever seen like her it was really like
her body gave out like that couldn't
really only happen when you like our ill
and you think when you're electrocuted
oh my god it was so good she looked like
she got electrocuted me every time she
got up she was thing ya know she's such
a good outfit that was really funny but
when she was in the room under the bed I
was like get the [ __ ] out if you ruin
this for your daughter like I'm done
with you because it really was such a
nice way and it was like chuckles why
here Vika there's a classic movie that
like she the mom would find her you know
but I'm glad that Leslie man got out oh
my god I'm so unless she got out I'm so
glad she got electrocuted and also like
okay uh Nick st. Claire was that was the
boyfriend and he was like such a nice
guy like at the prom first of all this
girl couldn't give two shits about him
just wants to hang out with her friends
and he was like letting her dance with
her friends like dancing behind her
being so supportive whereas like another
guy might have just like went off with
another girl what a dynamic actor Nick
st. Clara's really is he could play the
bad boy and I'm gonna die and I was just
like that's a great high school
boyfriend who like lets you be with your
friends do you see him in the background
taking Instagram photos for her while
they're waiting for the little dude this
was an amazing movie no he is the unsung
hero okay but you're you're skating past
the real reason I asked you I shudder I
tell you now no I tried no but you're
not gonna see it I know you won't even
like it no but I just have to watch out
Zach oh my god so you're really gonna
make me wait you said I could tell you
the car you like I'm trying my best to
watch it lucky it's my day
I'll watch you say before that gets home
no because then I'm not on the show
tomorrow and then Monday I'm gonna
forget it alright I'll give you one week
okay okay one racer it's okay I'll make
it if I don't make it happen this
weekend then I'm not making mm-hmm one
day is a lot to like watch a movie but
you you swore you were like I'm gonna
watch it today I know and I tried I
tried but the main effuse me just came
over and I was put through a tailspin
you were being so crazy with the Oh
lookey you see what he looked like when
my god she's heard when it was a little
dirt on his feet no washes and his belly
were soaked and picking up the streets
it wasn't even the city streets you just
you said yourself you underestimated how
wet it was outside I did my got a lie
but still just like you didn't need to
be something to him and now you've
you've bumped herself back down to
number two men's I not mean to him I
couldn't have been more see Oscar sighs
and when he got home he told me he was
like really upset about it I that's not
what he said me cuz he texted me later
and was like thank you for accommodating
me even though I showed up unannounced
and filthy well I took his phone away so
there's no way that he texted you must
have been it must have been steady
telegram it must have been spam um well
welcome to the morning toast Jackie and
I are gonna deliver as always too fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and we're gonna do
so in a premium mature slowed down
enunciated manner okay
first before we get into the Fast Five I
just wanted to give an update on a story
from yesterday we talked about Annabelle
Neilson firm ladies of London passing
away at the time there was no death but
it turns out that she did have a heart
attack in her home and all the ladies of
London stars have posted on Instagram I
think it took them a while to like
realize
this was all true um somewhere is to
Hermer posted cowling fleming posted
juliet posted and Caroline Stanbury
posted and also empty posted and well
didn't actually explicitly say that it
was her but John Doe linked up a recent
story with a blind and the blind was
just that she was dating like a very
wealthy married to like aristocratic
family and she was poisoned that's what
they say but when was she married to
this man because I don't think it's been
since the show it was years ago if she
was gonna like snitch on them what did
she have already done it maybe she was
making moves to snitch I don't know she
doesn't seem like a snitch honestly no
totally
I'm sure she's seen some things and she
never snitched yeah that's true she
wasn't born as me I don't know
especially it's definitely fishy any
time someone dies yeah there I go again
in a conspiracy theorist any time
someone dies yeah I agree
unless it's like an accident like a car
crash right and especially if there
aren't a lot of details about it you
know that's fishy er yeah anyway so
without further ado the official
pacified that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast first up Katy Perry had
situational depression after her album
flop okay this is kind of sad you guys
because I remember was about a year ago
we were making fun of bone Appetit on
this very show and while that brought me
so much joy and laughter like this is
really sad Katy Perry felt like she read
the stars all wrong following the
release of last year's witness album and
the negative response that followed this
is definitely true quote music is my
first love and I think it was the
universe saying okay you speak all of
this language about self love and
authenticity but we are going to put you
through another test and take away any
kind of validating blanky then we'll see
how much you do truly love yourself the
American Idol judge said in the August
issue of Vogue Australia despite
debuting atop the Billboard 200
witnessed garnered mixed reviews from
critics and fans alike
Perry 33 was painting as a result quote
I have had bouts of situational
depression and my heart was broken last
year because unknowingly I put so much
validity in the reaction of the public
and the public didn't react in the way I
had expected to which broke my heart
Perry retreated to California's Hoffman
Institute in January to focus on herself
for years my friends would go and come
back completely rejuvenated and I wanted
to go to Perry explained
I was
let go of anything that was holding me
back for myself the experience wasn't
lost on the pop star who says she since
grown from the set back that brokenness
plus me opening up to a greater higher
power and reconnecting with divinity
gave me a wholeness I never had it gave
me a new foundation it's not just a
material foundation it's a soul
foundation she said well while it is
very sad that like like it's just you'd
think celebrities are above at all but
like they read everything you know
mm-hmm well while all this was happening
it was like she was putting on bad song
after bad song like bad video bad
haircut like remember though there were
those memes she's like the new Miley
Cyrus like she had lost her mind
yeah and she had at in hindsight it
seems like she thought she was doing
everything right and the people were
gonna die for that like that's what
that's what you get when like you aren't
authentic right it was like you should
be nice and music video because you
think it's what people want to say you
should release it because you think it's
cool and an artistic expression of your
feelings shitty release a song called
bone Appetit no and you should like I
don't care and you know what else that
is like that means you're just
surrounding yourself with bad people
like if you're at a level that Katy
Perry is that like you have literally
100 people working for you and you need
to make sure that they're like they have
your best interests at heart I would
never put you on the table - you rolled
around in dough and needed by strange
men and like you did with a K unique
totally the people around here not in
tune with what's necessary like she's
like a very escape was like a very
established respected pop star and like
also very talented like that's something
that like I don't know do it but can be
doing right ya know she like lost her
way because she was one of the people
who like got to a level of Fame that was
like so crazy and like yes she has like
the glitz and the hair and the wigs but
she always was like a really good singer
and a really good songwriter like now
I'd like in this new era like I don't
even think of her as that anymore
right and that's what's sad yeah that's
what's sad cuz like when she went um
what was her album before that's called
the most amazing album ever um with
birthday o prism I was underrated album
a shoe and it's the most and I went to
the concert and it was like at the
concert of a lifetime because yesterday
the craziest stages the craziest outfits
everyone's clothes lit up but like she's
an incredible singer you know what I
think the problem is and Katy Perry it's
that she put out an amazing album prism
it was amazing songs that were not that
album was not respected it was not
thought of as a success the songs that
her team chose his singles birthday was
totally sung by a 12 year old totally
made her think that she needs me making
more songs like that but all the songs
that were ignored on prism were actually
wood the core of her talent and she
needed to make an album like the second
half of prism like rainbow this momento
- I can't and chant and it was such I
totally agree like but that made her
feel like she was doing something wrong
right and like that was so true to her
like this is like the actual set design
was like so Katy Perry like with the
like cupcake boobs like color that was
the old app no no but I'm saying right
that was the like the vibe of the set
like it was bright clothes balloons
everywhere animals like dancing mascots
like it was so Katy Perry without losing
like the good songs right but and I feel
like also even though there was a bunch
of crap on the stage like the cupcakes
meant something like when she did that
California video that she became the
cupcake queen now she just like throws
symbols on a stage animals that like
cats make sense for her and their kids
bands or her kid yeah that's you're
gonna throw some like lions and tigers
and bears oh my
for no reason they have to mean
something actually can't put a lion up
because of war
remember when she did the Super Bowl and
she was [ __ ] incredible no like
literally remember the music video for
roar like when she performed at the
Super Bowl
that was her Brun that was her prime I
watched her Super Bowl performance like
literally every day for two months and
how did we go from there to here I know
how the haircut she's Samson this goats
to show you that nothing good comes from
a pixie cut
Miley lost her mind when she cut her
hair it's like when a celebrity cuts
their hair that they're losing their
minds Britney it's a sit like we should
be worried about them I think literally
the day she cut her hair was like the
day we lost her yeah but it kind of
sounds like she's back like mentally
that she's self-aware present and I have
hope for her and as someone who at one
point was her biggest fan and into the
rhythm I'm done so at one point was her
biggest hater hater so I really can't
fit on both sides of the spectrum other
that's so true we used to love her I
used to I used to be my favorite artist
ever like in high school her putting out
an album that I hadn't listened to or a
song is wild to me the first concert I
ever went to it was Katy Perry when she
like just did hot and cold at Irving
Plaza I remember with Alex right after
you had gotten back in Church Street
[ __ ] oh
belly button peers yes that is exactly
what happened I'm so glad you had that
experience but I have hope
me too I'm sad that she was depressed
and like that we might have had
something to do with her depression just
like railing on her album but as an
artist you have to be open to critique
and like jumping out shitty music and
you don't listen to the people around
you get a new team well you know what
this reminds me of is the Lady Gaga
documentary which by the way is I think
one of my favorite documentaries like
about a celebrity ever it's so well done
and I just love Lady Gaga and she's just
literally like oozing with talent but
when her album got leaked early and like
people oh and there was a lot of like
backlash about what that song what was
the first song perfect illusion yeah
like and honestly when I first heard
Joanne like I didn't really give any
painting mind to it but then when we
went to Coachella
I like studied Joanne like I'm like the
months before and it's so good but like
I actually like I felt for her then
because I feel like Lady Gaga like pours
her heart and soul into every song she
writes the music she writes like the
melody where's like I feel like Katy
Perry just shows up these days these
days yeah but she has Lady Gaga running
through her veins like she's that kind
of artist like she can't be like so
invested in an album that I feel like
she had nothing to do with and you know
what Lady Gaga did go through that with
art pop I felt like she put out an album
that was like not very yes not very from
the heart in authentic and just what she
thought people wanted that was her last
album before she became like Stephanie
do you know what I mean like she was
stupid Chloe shipped it down ya know oh
my god that's so true like that album is
so bad I think it was just like she was
over like this image she had made for
herself and she was just doing what
people were telling her to do and you
could tell it wasn't her but then born
this way was literally like the album of
a lifetime exactly and same monster born
this way I think it's one of my feet I
agree
top five five favorite albums of all
time couldn't agree more there's so many
bang I didn't born this way itself is
the anthem I think of our generation
just like delirious it's the greatest
most amazing song on every use eclis
their spirituality and like every time
she performs it she really changes it
like the melodies and this country road
edition yep you and I I mean that's her
best song I think ever oh my god it's
crazy edge of glory is all from the
album you guys it's sure
scheisse scheisse uh yeah it's it's
really just a hair
we used to listen to that album all the
time all the time driving down the dirt
road going to camp in a convertible in a
convertible oh my god letting me dream
it we didn't even know and we didn't
even know it that's so true like what I
would do for that experience right now
well we're gonna be late we're totally
renting a convertible for chem toast and
we're listening to Born This Way out on
the entire way there happily and I would
drive back and forth and back and forth
to picking people up dropping them off
so sad for Katy Perry but like maybe
this will be like a great segue to her
like being back to her true roots and
releasing like amazing music I like the
level of of me not being here for it
it's reached its peak with change of the
rhythm even though the song ends up
growing on me but just like when she
when she performed it and like the whole
set was just like so not her and it was
just like it was so weird like and
justice for unconditionally that song
like uncondition the only reason why I
have a little bit of sympathy for
chained to the rhythm is because in
SoulCycle it's actually great song cuz
we really are all chained to the room
and everyone starts dancing and we're
chained to the rhythm and that's not a
reason to like a song but I say no it
made me like it more but one time go and
have a tea came on and so cycle and I
walked out I'm not gonna stand for this
no so I hope this is a new horizon for
Katy Perry's wish [ __ ] oh my god and
you know what I found out about that
that like I can't bleep you mourn
talking about the girl who invented
shook if do you know what that is no it
was like a video like it was like a vine
it wasn't your own eye eyes she is so
funny
I followed her on Twitter she's like an
influencer but I know her video went
viral I think about like Boston Market
being closed did you have a car she was
like I shook it it's so funny and Katy
Perry for this Phish Phish music video
got like a bunch of influencers and I
don't remember exactly what they did to
this girl but like everyone's like
nicknames were on the back and they had
her like in something like fat shaming
her I saw that and I remembered I sorry
I didn't really like my ditchin yes she
like tweet about it she's like I had no
idea that that's what they were bringing
me in the music video for I'm like I'm
so embarrassed like it was so mean
that's so mean that's so not cool that's
what I call also throwing influencers at
your music video like it's just never a
sound strategy but if it does that's it
okay next up Leslie Jones slams Jessica
Alba's honest company Wesley Jones is
one very
five customer of Jessica Alba's honest
company does all the chance of kids I
don't know
quote okay at honest you've just lost a
customer she wrote on Twitter Tuesday
afternoon at Jessica Alba please address
your company that is not doing good
business I have used your company for
more than three years now and these last
three orders have been a nightmare I
have spent too much money here for that
to happen the 50 year old Saturday Night
Live star had ordered extra diaper cakes
and paid extra for next day air for who
to shake in we're so sorry your order
was delayed the company we're back to
Jones our diaper cakes are handmade I
can take one to three days to process we
value your feedback and we're always
looking for ways to improve
we appreciate your love for honest thank
you for giving us the chance to make
this right Jones then angrily shot back
next day air should not be a [ __ ]
option it should be made clear that the
order is sent after processing which you
don't do it's not overnight if it gets
there in a week you charging me damn
near $50 for the last three orders were
late it wasn't like that before the
honest Co diaper cakes page has a
disclaimer that they say they will ship
within one to three days after the order
has been place it's unclear if the site
had the disclaimer before the exchange
with Jones Alba also took to Twitter to
send her apologies quote oh my god I'm
so so sorry you haven't had a great
experience she wrote we are all over
this issue and we'll make it right I am
so appreciative and grateful to you for
being a loyal honest fan over the years
especially as we go through these
growing pains I'm a huge fan of yours
that's kind of nice despite the apology
Jones stood by her Khan ending the
back-and-forth by stating she would find
diaper cakes elsewhere quotes so
disappointing because I've spent a lot
of money with y'all she wrote it's not
the first time Alba's company has come
under fire I thought of two ways about
this because like hey I think as
consumers like we're always getting
[ __ ] over and like you order something
you pay for shipping and like it doesn't
come and there's literally nothing you
can do about it and like we're always
losing like all the time and we're just
spending copious amounts of money to
lose okay but I also hate when people
like use their celebrity Kelly Cutrone
okay that's exactly my segue thank you
I'm so glad we have a plot anyone make
it a story either does that attention
but I just hate when people like use
theirs like if Leslie Jones was a
regular customer like I was like she
wouldn't be getting the CEO responding
to her so like what you should be
special you're going against your whole
point is that like you're a customer so
like I hate when people do that which
bring
wait I just want to wrap up this story
because that's a whole nother beast
Kelly I'm Kelly Bob I'll bob was like
being so right the fact that she didn't
say nice I understand Leslie Jones
reaction up until that point but once I
Jessica Alba tweet it's like this is her
company and and she works really hard
like apology accepted now send me my
fresh cakes for free one what are diaper
cakes no clue to like can't you what's
the rut like why do you need diaper
cakes right now because your baby's
hitting it spans Kelsey Johnson of kids
disease maybe was for like a bridal baby
shower or something and she needed the
fresh cakes okay I don't really
understand why like there's ever really
this diaper emergency like my can just
like run to the store and get but like
it just depends on your situation
tapirs also like well because honest
diapers are like they're all organic
right except apparently there was a suit
a lawsuit that said they use 11
synthetic ingredients that was the other
fire it's come under I don't know but I
like I was at Rebecca's house and she
has a new nephew and if he's Sneetches
and they had all these like baby
products and like they were all honest
like it really you know really like
great company and a lot of and it's
helped a lot of family so I'm using the
fact that their diapers just didn't
arrive that day like I just don't think
that's a pic of a deal on the grand
scheme of things no totally but I think
it wasn't it wasn't about that they
didn't arrive it was not that she paid
$50 and they for overnight and they
shipped it a week later which is so
annoying and unacceptable but like take
it up with a customer service rep right
and I'm sure that they would have
refunded you if you just like called
like a regular person or yes my leverage
your celebrity but then once Jessica
Alba apologizes like just accepted
diaper cakes are gifts to give at a baby
shower
socially engine I guess it's not urging
but she she ordered them for this baby
showers probably missed the window now
they're gonna come after the baby shower
which you just look like an ass showing
up without it and then like are you able
to give gifts at post shower or do they
have to be like a wedding you can give a
gift you know I here at the shower
because a part of the shower is opening
the yes yeah they totally have to bring
it no so yes oh it's a cake of diapers
like it's like Sex in the City
oh it wasn't it was a cake yeah that
Charlotte brought yes but now segue into
this Kelly Cutrone thing because I I
didn't know about I don't follow Kelly
Cutrone on Instagram but one of the
toasters put it in our Facebook group
they screen recorded her Instagram story
basically when it was raining the
there yes yesterday monsoon monkeys in
her and I think one of her friends like
got shelter underneath the scaffolding
and there was a homeless men underneath
the scaffolding like macerating um and
they like ran and called the police and
I guess the police took like a super
long time to come she says two hours and
she videoed herself on the phone with
the 9-1-1 operator yelling like crazy so
rude at this 9-1-1 operator who seemed
just like a nice girl trying to do her
job she was like I am a New York Times
bestselling author I have a a huge
social media following 135,000 people
I'm filming this I'm gonna speak to the
supervisor like screaming screaming
screaming she was like I was just
sexually assaulted and no one has come
it's been two hours
the lady who literally can't be helpful
in anything other than just telling the
police like it's it's not this woman's
fault whatsoever and she literally was
like they're on their way and I just
thought first of all it's like so cringy
when people are like do you know how
many followers I have a that wield
they're celebrities like che against the
fuzz right now even the fuzz a 9-1-1
operator she's not even a like a cop
like right he is operator like oh my god
then like also justice doesn't serve you
just because you have instagram no and
some of made the greatest point she was
like I live in Soho so with what you
live in Soho you think you get priority
over other people to the police like no
they rank it based on like urgency like
if there was a write a shooting and
someone was running like they're you
know what any they're not gonna wait two
hours I I find it hard to believe that
the cops are sitting in their station
eating doughnuts being like oh Kelly
Cutrone called let's go in two hours
like please I just thought it was so and
like it's raining so you know there's
like more accidents like it was just
such an abuse of power and then like
putting it on our Instagram so he made
it look so bad like I watched the video
a hundred times I couldn't believe I
couldn't even finish the video because
like it was making me sick listening to
her talk that way and all I was thinking
is like oh yeah bro being exposed to is
unfortunate and I know it happens every
day in New York City it's essentially a
rite of passage
just leave the scaffolding call the
police let them know right a exposed man
on this in such corner and move on with
your life that's literally would happen
to us we were on down the street and
meatpacking there's a man sitting on a
throne of garbage with his weenie out
and guys
it was the biggest Fitness I ever saw it
was literally the size of this like I
was like at first any think it was a
penis because I'm like it's nothing big
I my goodness sure it's like a water
bottle or something it was huge
so me and we worth Kristin yeah read
like for our lives ran down this should
we turned the corner called the police I
just want to let you know there's a
homeless man on Washington Street
you know wielding his penis like what do
you even turn like a like a turn like a
I don't know just like this yeah it was
crazy and and we left and they were like
thank you right no no and by the way as
a citizen of New York she has every
right to call the police like she is a
victim of sexual misconduct but to like
rail on this girl like that was like so
uncalled for and she made herself look
so bad like I couldn't believe when she
was like I live in Soho what does that
make you better and it's like she's
recording this posting and thinking like
she is a victim and the whole world is
gonna see it from her point of view when
like she looks like an [ __ ] and only
an [ __ ] would think that they don't
look like an aspirate she put that video
out there thinking people would be like
on her side like I can't believe that
happened to you right that makes her
look so bad it makes her look so bad I
mean she did already like is people
don't think of her like is it the
kindness you know most generous just
makes me think she's just entitled and
right leave New York City if you can't
handle seeing a penis no I disagreed
like okay it's it's a jarring thing and
it doesn't happen to Ed run it's very
frequent but like when it happens to you
like it's crazy and she did the right
thing calling the police but like just a
the way she spoke to that woman be like
the lack of respect she had and like see
the fact that she thought like everyone
was after her I couldn't chug it I
literally never get this I live in Soho
what does that mean I live on the Upper
East Side congratulations
it's called helicoptering yes
helicoptering
you guys is the craziest thing ever and
I didn't even know what to do about it
like I just I was shocked we were like
but we just kept moving it happened to
my friend Alicia on the train in Paris a
guy opened his jacket Wow
I know it happens like a frequently it's
so disgusting world we live in and we
shouldn't normalize it no and we're not
normalized
but like the way that she reacted you
would have think something truly
horrible happened that the police
weren't there on the scene that minute
and you know what on the list of New
York City emergencies like it's an
attitude that's just a way they say God
the table no totally and she was
screaming at the lady she's like the
precinct is two blocks away how wide is
it taking them so long
okay the two priests and she walks away
go walk there go tell them you do it
save the city some resources I can't so
crazy I literally was Chuck and so she
was just standing there like next him
for two hours no she was in her
apartment when she called it was in her
neighborhood on her way home
I don't know so how did she know that
the police didn't go right cuz it
happened outside but she was inside
right maybe she just had was on the
phone for two hours she couldn't get
nowhere he phone said three minutes I
saw I was thinking the same thing who
knows you guys oh and then she was
stunned sick I'm gonna call page six
what the hell is page six gonna say now
they're gonna write an article about her
story that she looks like an ass but
what did she date like Kelly Cutrone was
mistreated by police they don't even go
I'm sorry but you've mistreated Kelly
Cutrone honestly I'm so afraid of Kelly
Cutrone
I really hope nobody sends us sir I'm
sure somebody will and no she's fine but
like just respect the system it is what
it is don't abuse your power get me
wrong it's gonna be zero hundred thirty
five in social media files because
they're not following I think definitely
right define it with the police you get
like this isn't Delta you don't get to
pay more for priority because you live
in Soho it definitely sucks that the
police took so long to come but like
relax and I'm sure she was exaggerating
with the two hours cuz I know if I was
in that situation I would want to make
it look my worst I would say two hours
it's probably 45 minutes totally yeah
okay speaking of people who are out of
control on social media Elon Musk
apologizes to the cave rescuer for a
pedo tweet a backhand apology Elon Musk
has apologized for calling one of the
men involved in the ty cave rescue
mission a pedo or pedophile the Tesla
CEO has faced an intense backlash over
the unfounded claim against Vernon
Unsworth an expert caver who
participated in the rescue mission that
saved 12 boys in their soccer coach from
a flooded cave in Thailand musk
expressed remorse on Twitter the
executives said that while Unsworth
provoked him quote his actions against
me do not justify my actions against him
for that I apologize to mr. Unsworth and
to the companies I represent as leader
the fault is mine and mine alone and
he's like yeah basically you said mean
things change so I said the Mac and I'm
sorry for my part in it like a
two-year-old apology that's how I
apologize to everyone written by a 40
year old and you know what I think he
covered his bases I think he means it
I'm sure he got like a lot of backlash
from the shareholder yeah and felt the
need to apologize but you know what I
feel like for a man like Elon Musk it
takes a lot for him to like feel like
he's in the wrong right a slot for him
to even apologize so I personally accept
his apology now I do few people make
mistakes it's not a big deal like it
just it makes it so much worse when the
person you're insulting is like a
national an international hero Rio right
yes as one international hero you feel
like you can insult another that's true
but you very good point but you can't no
matter who you are you can't insult an
international hero that's the lesson
learned even it could I guess that
international hero insulted Elon first
so in international that's true what
about why are we talking like that that
was because he didn't and he didn't like
LIBOR him as Elon went below the belt
it's like real house size yeah even if
someone is once you go the below the
belt you're wrong automatically even if
you the reasons for calling them below
the belt are right that that was like my
problem growing up it's like I'm going
to fight two people and I was totally
right but then I'd be like I hope you
burn in hell and like then I'm locked
then I lose yeah or if you hate someone
you lose that's that's my problem but
like that seems unfair I disagree do you
know what I mean no I I think it has to
be this way and then like the whole
basis of the argument like just that
feeling and then you lose everything
like everything that burns said to you
I'm like that was so [ __ ] up to that's
also defamatory saying that he's only
doing good for us for good press [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
totally but you learn do you need to
apologize was actually like defamatory
in the court of law so that's why I
don't need to apologize to each other or
just literally forget about one another
cuz the odds of them seeing each other
again are very low you never know it's a
small world and it's made even smaller
by Elon Musk and then hyperlapse yeah
and his tunnels Hyperloop whatever
hyperlapse is where the audio anyways
I'm proud of you Elon keep up the good
work
get back to get back to work we're
waiting to go to Mars with bated breath
we're gonna be the official Mars
correspondent of course live
from Mars I only weigh like six pounds
in morning Mars I only weigh like six
and half pounds in Mars that's that's
literally enough reason to move I
couldn't agree more except like the lack
of food and life is like it's down there
first everyone's bringing it all and
also like you on will be there so we've
always wanted to meet him that's true we
have to go to Mars in order to know I'm
definitely down for Mars it's AB like
we'd have to figure out the food thing
maybe they don't like to travel you know
even to like that's true and I wonder if
they have first class on on NASA and if
we would get it as like the talent that
they're bringing for sure it's like that
movie passengers one movie and I pretty
sure Jennifer Lawrence and Chris Pratt
hooked up on that with me
they hooked up and they died oh they did
yeah because you're allowed to spoil
that but on that island
I thought you sorry you were acting like
you saw well anyhow why was it acting
like that I didn't even say it
yeah I was like it says to make a movie
passengers in here are like yeah and
they hooked up I don't think that's true
I think it's true I wouldn't have
spoiled I'm anti spoilers well you
didn't even give a spoiler alert which
is what you're supposed to do proper
conduct sorry I just assumed it's not a
movie that you have to see people if
they die that's crazy well cuz can I say
now so they're on a ship to like a new
planet and it's gonna take hundreds of
years so they put them into like almost
his coma so what like awesome power
style their frozen Walt Disney style so
when they wake up they're young and
sprightly and they're colonizing a new
land however Chris Pratt's coma machine
frozen machine is defected he wakes up
in the middle of the journey has no one
to talk to and it's just like living
there I think for like a year before he
wakes up Jennifer Lawrence cuz he like
became obsessed with her profile through
looking through the databases and so the
two of them are alive they can't
refreeze themselves they have hundred
years before they get to the planet and
they live together on the ship for and
how do they jet they kill themselves
no they just they they die of old age
because they were interred here on the
ship for so long sounds horrible
horrible you know what that reminds me
of now I'm gonna spoil movie for you but
I know you're never gonna see it you
meant they hooked up in real life yes oh
okay I understand why you thought I saw
now no they hope that's what people say
is like the reason him and Anna Anna
Faris broke up unfounded but wait well
then why wouldn't they be together now
that movie like [ __ ] me up because I
thought of being with one person on a
spaceship for like the next 60
like makes me want to die but it's like
a cool spaceship and there's a pool and
a bar and every little shirt but that
gets old really quick no you had to
really love the person right and even if
you like I really love that I would not
want to even like be with him for that
amount of time but that reminds me of
did you ever see ex machina no oh my god
that's not its own idea and I watched it
literally by accident it's the craziest
movie it's like this this like tech nerd
gets invited to like this to tech moguls
house and it's all like a crazy like
digital house with robots and everything
he falls in love with the robot yeah he
falls in love with the robot Alicia
vikander and the robot like gets smarter
than the humans and ends up killing the
tech mogul and locking the tech nerd in
the Moghuls house for eternity
he'd have to die in that house oh my god
that second game of Thrones where like a
nice girl betrays her and she locks them
in a book involved yes with with that
tall guy that's truly totally know like
this sometimes things happen in movies
or like an SVU then I'm like oh my god
like I can't even imagine that happening
to me like girl in the and they when she
pulled in SVU when they pull out the
nanny and she's gonna turn up in the
desktop and it's also like it makes me
realize like Hollywood is like so [ __ ]
up to even think of these things yeah
you know totally like who's twisted
[ __ ] mind thought to put a nanny in a
trundle someone who put their nanny in a
trundle is it called a trundle or yeah
pick up that wait that's the technical
term I thought it was like a family word
no no it's just like we actually are
using the correct word for something
that's so rare it is very rare rare
parsed out to be an artist yeah okay
sorry oh so wait there was a comment
that I owe on Mars II way more on the
moon you way less oh damn we are not
going to the moon that's just what I
needed it more weight definitely not we
I'm officially turning down the offer to
correspond for Elon Musk and Mars I'm
wasn't available the Royals are an
embarrassment for being so cold Megan
Markos half sister Samantha blasts her
Dutchess sibling for quote ignoring
their father and says if he dies
meg is responsible Samantha Marvel went
on like a crazy Twitter rant and she I
think has a private Twitter but the
screenshots obviously got out there
these are the same these are the
screenshots my father is not an
embarrassment for loving his daughter
the Royals aren't embarrassed
for being so cold you should be ashamed
of yourselves at Kensington Royal oh
yeah like they're gonna respond to you
[ __ ] she's glad you have so much time
to gallivant around paying tribute to
others while ignoring their own father
how cold can you be and look in the
mirror Harry I guess I was right and
then she did a link to the Daily Mail
story was had pictures of Harry and
Megan visiting the Nelson Mandela
memorial and she said how about you pay
tribute to your own father enough is
enough
act like a humanitarian act like a woman
if our father dies I'm holding you
responsible Meg damn at Kensington rail
again literally every time one of the
extended family members of Megan Marvel
speaks like I just want to be like so
not smart because if you played your
cards right you could be dining with
Queenie vibes only yeah for the rest of
time no totally I'm sure Megan wanted to
put on a front that she had a normal
family so if everyone just [ __ ]
behaves for like a week today they would
have gotten exactly what they wanted
they would have gotten invited to the
wedding they could have been rubbing
elbows with Victoria Beckham and instead
you're tweeting from your private
account
I don't think Samantha Markel and Megan
Merkel are really related they might
have a thing and they might just have
the same dad right with different
because Thomas Merkel's her real dad
yeah and it seems like Thomas Merkel is
Samantha's real dad from the way she's
defending him right but Megan Merkel's
mom is definitely not Samantha Markel's
no and we're maybe yeah for sure because
they're half sisters right and if -
right so I just I can't image with like
you know what every family has dirty
laundry but like this is next-level like
get it together I don't know why we'd
get for being like a good sister right
now when all she needs is people close
to her that she'd be like you're a [ __ ]
totally and I don't know why I like the
Royals and Megan aren't doing a better
job of like getting these people
wrangled they're literally like wild
horses that you need to wrangle together
and get them to behave like they're so
embarrassing that like if they just
reached out to the dad and like
literally moved him into a palace like
took away his phone like it would fix
all their problems do you don't I mean
yeah I'm sure Thomas Markel would still
find a way to talk to the Daily Mail
even if he was like chained up like
Cinderella in a palace but without a
but it would help it would definitely
help but she thinks ignoring it is gonna
make it go away but there she's making
it worse she's infuriating them even
more by ignoring them and she's
embarrassing it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing but I don't know I kind of
understand why Megan is ignoring them
and I think that I would do the same
thing it's like I like the minute she
speaks out about it or like gives it
legitimacy like true Samantha Marco goes
from being like a wild conspiracy
theorist to like being in a duel with
the crown right I guess that's true it's
like below them to even engage right
that's like and it also makes it seem
like what Samantha Markel is saying has
a little bit of elyda t yeah they're
even bothering to respond to it totally
so I think I would actually go the
silent route but they're out of control
they're so out of control and it's like
we're all so out of control because the
more that they do this stuff with Maurey
report on it we're forming it they like
are like yeah what does Samantha Markel
want out of this so that's what I'm
curious I because if it is to be close
with the Queen she's going about it the
wrong way
just like Fame and her name in the Daily
Mail and on the morning toast yeah she's
getting everyone's working because
there's no way she actually wants Megan
to like be close to her cuz this isn't
the way to go about it well when we read
we were talking about this in the cab
and I opened the tweets and it said
Samantha Markel for some reason I read
Samantha McCain and I was like I said to
Jackie I'm like Megan and it's Megan
McCain Megan Marco I was like Megan has
a sister you're like yeah she's crazy
you don't I really thought your amnesia
was this was off the chart but I was
like you're the one who told me about
her right so I thought that McCain's
have like a crazy sister and I'm like
why is this first I'm hearing of this
and then like I was obviously just like
tired and then everything that clicked
I'm like oh the Markel OC I know her
Samantha old Sammy Jo I know her old
Sammy Marco I just I look I look forward
to this episode of the crown because
that's the only way we get to see what's
actually happening inside the palace
right but like how do they know um like
correspondence letters snitches emails
yeah and then like whoever is Megan
Markos private secretary now eventually
won't be in 40 years no one will really
care about the minutia right so it all
is all very interesting no this is just
such a great time to be alive it really
is but I feel like it's always you know
it's always something with them like
even when it was Diana like I'm sure
those stories were wild right no they
always have drama and it's like the
crown never spoke about it yeah were
they thinking silver we still don't know
but we're coming up to a time when it's
gonna be talked about in the crown I'm
really excited to see how they handle it
yeah totally
okay fifth and final story is a real
conversation starter literally woman
whose plane meet-cute went viral says
tweets were an invasion of privacy not a
quote romance so for those of you who
don't know the story of plane BAE
Claudia is here to recount it to you so
there was a thread that went like crazy
viral on Twitter I think I was like a
hundred thousand retweets about this
couple this girl was on a plane and her
and her boyfriend were like not seated
next to each other so they asked the
woman stood next the husband if she
would switch so she ended up sitting
next to her husband and ended up moving
this girl young girl next to the ceiling
cute guy and this girl's Instagram story
is documented the whole thing cause like
she really thought they were hitting it
off and like they were talking the whole
time they even like rubbed elbows the
girl like kept buying Wi-Fi to update
everyone on Twitter it was like a crazy
thread where like when she got off the
plane she was like I really feel like I
made a match she was taking pictures the
whole time but just she was sitting
behind them so she was taking a picture
of the gap between the seats so you
could see their arms you couldn't see
their face and then at the end she took
a picture of them and like totally
blurred out their faces you couldn't see
she covered it with marker and it went
viral and like this really positive like
really cute it was just like a cute
thing I know what the girls intentions
were like it was great content and be
like she really thinks she like set them
up for life so she never said who they
were she never took pictures of them but
the guy like after the plane the guy
like found out it went viral and found
out it was him and like used it as like
thirst monster central on his Instagram
and he basically said that he's been in
contact with the girl and he followed
her on Instagram and said her name was
Helen
so in him doing that he gave everyone
the opportunity to go through who
efallai was cuz obviously his public
he's a thirst monster fine Helen and
just braid her like non-stop so it
turned into like this crazy negative
thing because now this girl's being like
docks by crazy psychotic
freaks on the Internet and I think there
might be something shady I think she has
a boyfriend but she didn't Lee do
anything wrong she was just talking like
right but it gave me insinuation that
like she when she went to the bathroom
I'm like you know but they join
mile-high
but it really it's like sometimes when
your seatmate goes to the bathroom you
go to because we don't have a sense in
getting up twice totally so now it's
like the girl had to apologize the girl
who did the content and I'll read it
because it's like it's a crazy apology
like she feels so bad this girl in a
statement to Business Insider the woman
who chose to remain anonymous Helen I
guess spoke out about how her private
conversation became a very public story
without her consent quote I am a young
professional woman on July 2nd I took a
commercial flight from New York to
Dallas without my knowledge or consent
other passengers photographed me and
recorded my conversation with a see me
they posted images and recordings to
social media and speculated unfairly
about my private conduct she said in a
statement provided to the outlet by her
lawyer since then my personal
information has been widely distributed
online strangers publicly discussed my
private life based on patently false
information I have been doxed shamed
insulted and harass she added I did not
ask for and do not seek attention
hashtag plain BAE is not a romance it is
a digital age cautionary tale about
privacy identity and ethics and consent
she continued before asking people to
quote respect my privacy and my desire
to remain anonymous so then the girl who
had initially wrote written the threat
whose name is Rosie she released this
statement on Twitter and it's like she
feels so bad Jacki I don't know what to
do I'm at a loss when I made this and I
shared it I was happy joyful and
overcome with authentic and sincere
excitement so much so that I could not
see the potential exploitative nature of
the outcome of my actions the last thing
I want to do is remove agency and
autonomy from another woman I wish I
could communicate the shame I feel in
having done this but I truly feel that
at this point my feelings are irrelevant
this may be coming too little too late
I've been instructed by peers with
experience similar waves of positive and
negative attention to let it blow over
that does not sit well with my conscious
conscience I've sat on this silently for
a few days now Helen to you although
you're not much of an Internet fan I
hope you see this
I apologize for utilizing what could
have been a beautiful charming moment
among strangers as a tool to communicate
a narrative I am fond of I apologize for
taking what should have been a small
mundane moment of cheeriness and turned
it into something foul and over
amplified I apologize for taking away
something that I myself valued quite a
bit which is sharing one's own story
publicly as a means to inspire others
what I have done is in no way
inspirational every woman has a right to
her own story and to have taken away
yours and turned it into my own was
wrong in many levels Helen to you I
offer my services in whatever way you
wish to continue the story it's now
yours as it
should have been this entire time
whatever decision you come to I'm
humbled in to honor it and will work to
right this wrong so now people are
really like of like two mindsets like is
this a crazy invasion of privacy or is
this like so dramatic I am really torn
me too oh and here's the here's the
thing I don't think what the girl Rosie
did was wrong at all and I think if it
were anyone else they would be so
excited just like the man to be involved
in this someone a toaster said that she
might have had a boyfriend so I can
understand why she'd be pissed but it's
like it's just unfortunate that it
happened to me this girl who's not who
really is averse to being public because
the most of the world is so thorough and
would dream of being involved it's just
bad luck that the girl who it was is
like not thirsty because everyone is and
if given the opportunity to like some
Instagram thought like she would be
milking this left right and center
growing on GMA and like marrying this
guy just so that they could get like a
free TV wedding right and that would
have been like the really happy way it
ended but you know what things don't
always work out that way and so as much
as like when this was happening I was
like this is a perfect use of like the
Internet and so many people have like
live tweeted their flights and it's
always so negative it's like my the guy
sitting next me he's a nut job right
like smells like quoting everything that
they say two people are breaking up on a
flight like so this was a really nice
use of this you know live tweet right
like when people livestream other people
like been that girl went viral for
tweeting the live tweets of a couple
breaking up on the plane Exeter and put
pictures of their faces like that I
understand is a complete invasion of
privacy cuz it's a spotlight on
something negative and she put their
faces out there right so I felt like
when this all happened I thought it was
like really cute and if this girl didn't
have such anniversary action to it I
would still think was cute like there's
no reason why things like this shouldn't
happen more it's a really great use of
the internet finally something we can
all agree on in like finally something
on Twitter is going viral for something
positive right so I really am all about
it but it is an invasion of privacy
honestly like if I were on a plane and I
happen to be a very thirsty person and I
found out someone was tweeting
everything I said and it's like I'm not
thinking of what I'm saying and like
just it it's a creepy feeling yes and
it's it's it's creepy so I understand
both sides people calling on Rosie to
apologize though is like so dramatic
because honestly if that thirst monster
guy didn't blow this
girls cover like this thing would have
just ended the way it started which was
like nice happy move on to the next
thing that goes viral like and like it's
just so classic that like nobody no one
is really pointing out that like this
guy is at fault like he took away her
autonomy like yes what what the girl did
is like creepy and that's a sense of
like she wrote down a couple of things
that the girl said but like she never
showed her face the mo she ever did was
show her arm like so I thought this girl
handled it and that when she was when I
was following the thread I was like show
us her face show us her face like well I
want to look up the girl and I wasn't
able to like as a normal person and then
I moved past it yes there are psychos on
the internet who would further look for
her but like where's where's his apology
and also I agree that it's his fault
that her name got out and this is just
the problem with the Internet's like we
can't have nice uh-huh you can't enjoy a
story without knowing who she is where
she lives telling her she's a [ __ ] bla
bla bla like can't we just like enjoy
people on the internet without having to
know every single thing about them enjoy
a nice story on the internet without
having to put a face to the name like
totally I I feel like it's our fault as
people for just needing to know like oh
my god whether this is the same thing as
the plastic the plastic yeah it's the
humans fault it's not the Internet's
fault it's not the plastics fault it's
the humans we need to fix ourselves
instead of getting rid of straws we need
to fix ourselves instead of making this
girl apologize I agree I understand I
think it's just unfortunate that
something so cute and pure and positive
had to turn into something so ugly and
crazy like I feel so bad for this girl
Rosie you know she has the biggest Pitt
of all time and she doesn't deserve it
no and what her tone and like the voice
that like that she was putting on these
messages was like so like hopeless
romantic sweet like she's not a bad
person
whatsoever got home like in Dallas and
she liked her reaction to finding out
that they like well apart or an
Instagram or like that everyone was so
excited like that was like pure joy and
so for to go from that feeling to be
like oh my god I did something horrible
is a fart it's a big drop and my
thoughts I do not envy the pit she
currently has no I do not I just like
honestly your friends are right this too
shall pass waiting blow over you
apologize you did everything you could
you brought us a little bit of anything
wrong you brought something nice to the
Internet congratulations it's hard to do
we do it every day but you know
other people can't so no good pretty
perfectly like this is truly why we
can't have nice things
this is why like as much as I love the
world we live in I also despise it like
we are the worst sometimes like we can't
just enjoy something and move on like we
have to beat it to a pulp that it turns
into something negative right but that
is our generation because we truly
cannot have a nice thing no because we
just need to shatter it on the floor no
bislane Bay has officially been
shattered yeah thanks I really enjoyed
it in its heyday like in its prime you
know what I have to be honest I watched
I it's nice to meet me sometimes because
I looked at the Twitter thread in its
prime and I was like oh what a sweet
story and because I'm not on Twitter I
never got all the follow-up until you
said let's talk about playing mate today
well I didn't really see I saw that like
there was some like low-level
journalists like writing about how it's
an invasion of privacy like making other
people are content and I was like who
cares about these people then someone
did a thread in the morning toasters and
I was like and then I happened Dennis
followed up yeah but like when like
weenies who write for like BuzzFeed
wrote about it like who cares they're
upset about everything at BuzzFeed so my
classic another cog in the machine
I'm just being upset about stuff really
just said about their job and they're
turning green episode because we talked
about what life was like when we worked
like for about that wasn't a regular
episode right when we when like I had
just a regular nine-to-five job like
even before the old show and how I
showed up to dinner one night and the
family told me I looked green from work
so I hope you guys aren't turning green
over there yeah
but part of me hopes you are
was there any TV I feeling the toast
helps people turn not green yeah no
totally like this is the two hours a day
where your Center your face like where
the blood like rushes here you know if
you're like a fully invested toaster and
you not only watch the show in the
mornings but then are involved in all
the groups and subgroups during the day
in patreon and b-tree I'm like you have
a full day of work covered totally you
probably should leave like 30 minutes to
get work done but who needs more than
that no you're efficient you don't need
95 get your $1.99 30 or my kids like 12
or 13 no like I would say like 2 to 4
was there any team down last night no I
watched blockers and then I watched
longest ride and I can't
movie without crying they released the
seating chart for Real Housewives of New
York reunion
Ramona I looked up every picture from
every union for the past ten seasons and
Ramona has been seated next to Andy and
about like five of them and their more
recent likes now she's like cemented
herself was like a real house like the
icon whereas in the beginning she was
like in the middle between like you know
cool Jill Zarin right so she's been like
cemented that's like a real like staple
staple and so the fact that a she wasn't
seated next to Andy was big but then the
fact that carol was it's like member one
bill and Jeff and Bill and Jeff any Jill
and Bethenny he's like when they were
both seated on either side and he was
just like non-stop the whole day and
that's what it's gonna be with that
thing Carol and I have to be honest I
blame LuAnn for this seating chart
missing because it would have been LuAnn
it shouldn't have been Carol does not
deserve the top seat no you don't get
the top seat just because you're mean to
Bethenny like right it should have been
well but also Bethenny and LuAnn might
have been on the same couch but then
maybe better have been next to Andy huh
I don't know what would have been that's
also like this all all this LuAnn stuff
is so crazy and like her she's back in
rehab but she has to be in court in Palm
Beach like in a few days but the rehab
she was in before was in Florida so
maybe it's the same one
okay maybe and then like the fact just
what's crazy is that she posted that she
was six months over on Instagram when
like she wasn't no what's crazy is NT
and he had a blind like literally two
years know that countess LuAnn no it
didn't say countess LuAnn but it was
like this reality star who is a royal
whatever has been using her children's
inheritance and trust funds to buy like
to live her life and then it came out
like literally a week ago that the count
and the kids are suing LuAnn for taking
money from their trust funds to like buy
a house in Sag Harbor that's crazy
and that's crazy we called it also what
is crazy is that she's been on since the
first season in different roles yes but
she hasn't yet to like turn her presence
into a business she is sort of now with
the Cabaret but that's not like of the
book plus with the countess well not
everyone does that especially in New
York but they shouldn't OC they do like
where they're thirsty they do like The
OC girls need that in like a revenue
she's been divorced for a while now know
her financials confuse me yeah and like
she doesn't have a house no so and she's
using her kids money so she knew she
didn't have money
and she doesn't go and start a business
or a line on QVC I totally agree and
even the cabaret shows she's only done
like five or six and the one I went to
where she does most them is like a very
small venue we can't fit more than like
50 people it's great for her brand and
I'm glad she's doing it but in terms of
money making like she's yet to like turn
this into a real opportunity so trend
she's a smart woman so I don't
understand that also I watch watch what
happens live last night with Tamra and
Shannon mhm and Shannon beador is the
cutest woman alive and she no no Claudia
she was being so cute first of all she's
lost 24 pounds total she's really being
like I'm old happy self again okay and
she's like dating and anytime someone
mentioned it she's literally like I feel
like I'm watching happen sighs there's
no time for like Miss speaking more for
taint words for talking so and literally
for ten seconds she's like stop stop so
she was like so embarrassed writing read
and she just like seems really cute and
like her face is like coming back to
like the face of like we knew from the
earlier seasons and I'm just really
happy for her she was even like spilling
tea on David I guess because she looks
so good he went he came to pick up the
kids the other day and she goes hey
David look at this and pulled up her
shirt because she was like so proud of
so cute and like you have to watch this
episode because it will remind you of
the show of why we are one should
support Shannon even though last season
she wasn't herself
yeah the thing with watch happens live
is I totally agree that it's way too
quick and like some most episodes that
like I tune into our like because I love
the people and like you really want the
dish and like I find that Andy's always
rushing people through questions and
like rushing through games and rushing
through everything they don't get time
to think of a good answer because there
is no time to think right I like and I
think an hour would be way too much and
30 minutes is good but it's not 30 it's
like 21 because of commercials so I
think they have to find an end like that
Bravo after show like I'm not watching
that they need to figure out a way to
make watch up in five like 45 minutes so
that that they can have like 30 minutes
of like hard content yeah and it's like
what parts of watch what happens I've
could you live without because they feel
like sometimes the games are unnecessary
but they have to play them every episode
but when it's like non Bravo people like
so I when it is Bravo people like they
don't need to play games like when
celebrities play games about other
celebrities like that's cool or at
somebody play games about Bravo people
do you see dream cuz Kowski watch happen
side she's the biggest below detect and
they gave trivia with her where was like
intense questions like
how much was the tip for the biggest tip
of the season she got it right it was
like 21,000 her she is the biggest fan I
those are the best episodes and Kristin
Cavallari was on with Sonja Morgan and
she's a big real honey fan huh and that
was cute too yeah you know sometimes
it's like I mean if you think about it
they have to do five episodes a week
with two guests each and like you do run
out of celebrities at some point and
they read like they come on multiple
times but like there's only so many
people that can so sometimes a bike
stinky guests yeah like Michelle Collins
I could really live without I don't like
her at all I don't know I turn on the
episode process and it was chibi models
whose names I had never heard of when I
was like I'm good no those are the worst
but like at the same time it's like you
got a like Phil's a man they do 10
episodes a week
let me five episodes weekly 10 yes no
totally god forbid you have us on got
that it would matter to get upset is
that all
I think so new episode of her homie
tonight can't wait episode of honey
tonight can't wait I have to talk about
with Steve Magee cuz you won't be here
tomorrow make sure you come in on our
Instagram with questions for Steven yeah
I want to know what the hell happened to
summer house cuz I don't really know I
want to know why him in Lauryn workus
are the ones who got booted like I know
why this two new people got booted cuz
they stunk but him in Boren I actually I
really just wanna know why he got there
did ya like he was like to me like the
show isn't great but to me he was always
just like a bright spot and being like
funny sassy I agree
we'll get the T great that's all she
wrote I will see you all hopefully in
st. Louis and then in Denver but I'm
back on Monday and it should be a good
time please be nice to my sister while
I'm gone
treat her nicely thank you anything else
nope just have a holiday y'all make sure
you're following the morning toast on
Instagram Facebook YouTube and Twitter
podcast - what else I think that's all
and then make sure if out and girl
wasn't a job jackieo problems pop within
a job in tiffany thornton boy with no
job club with no job Marga sure a body
bison H Olivia shrine yeah whatever
throne follow bye guys have a good one
you